the U.S treasury is warning Congress
that the government could run out of
cash to pay its bills in less than a
month if lawmakers don't raise the debt
limit this deadline means more
uncertainty for our economy that has had
recent bank failures and continuing
inflation Nancy Cortez is at the White
House Nancy good morning
good morning Nate we are now starting to
see a little bit of movement President
Biden called all four Congressional
leaders on Monday and invited them to a
meeting next Tuesday here at the White
House to discuss the debt limit this new
alert from the treasury Department is
only adding to the pressure to reach a
resolution quickly
for over 200 years
America has never ever ever failed to
pay its debt that record could be tested
in just four weeks according to treasury
secretary Janet Yellen in a letter to
Congressional leaders Monday she warned
that the government won't be able to
meet its Financial Obligations
potentially as early as June 1st unless
the debt limit is raised or suspended by
Congress we pay our bills and we should
do so without Reckless hostage taking
from some of the mega republicans in
Congress the bill is passed
House Republicans
limit but the bill included a range of
steep spending cuts targeting many of
President Biden's priorities Senate
Democrats say that bill is Dead on
Arrival
on his first foreign trip as house
Speaker Kevin McCarthy spoke about the
debt ceiling from Israel saying the bill
should be a starting point for
negotiations we will not pass the debt
scene that just raises it without doing
something about our debt while the U.S
has never defaulted on its debt it did
come close during a similar fight in
2011 which rocked the markets and led to
a downgrade of U.S credit the president
of the United States needs needs to see
the reality see the writing on the wall
and do the right thing Greg McBride
Chief Financial Analyst at bank rate
says a failure to act could have even
more serious consequences this time
around that certainly doesn't get raised
all bets are off we will have a
recession and it won't be allowed
this added uncertainty comes as the
Federal Reserve is still trying to deal
with the impact of high inflation today
the FED begins a two-day meeting to
decide whether to increase interest
rates again and by how much all of this
scale is high stakes for the White House
the state of the economy of course will
be pivotal to the president's
re-election prospects
all right we'll all be watching thank
you Nancy